time for et's social study celebs hang
out after the holidays Jerry Seinfeld's
kids are all grown up the comedians in
cars getting coffee star and his wife
Jessica shared these picture perfect
shots of the family during their winter
getaway
it's a rare shot of their three kids
Shepherd Sasha and Julianne the caption
if we make it to 2017 it will be a
miracle 2017 is shaping up to be a good
one for Miley Cyrus and boyfriend Liam
Hemsworth the couple shared some cute
snaps from their holiday festivities
over the weekend including this pajama
party with their rescue dog Dora and
this heartfelt pic of Miley given Liam a
cinch on the cheek meanwhile Julianne
Moore and her look-alike daughter hit a
Knicks game in New York City over
Christmas Julianne and 14 year old Liv a
front lick are the spitting image of
each other check out that trademark
gorgeous red hair clearly good genes run
in the family and Mila Kunis is looking
flawless stepping out for breakfast with
hubby Ashton Kutcher on Monday the 33
year old actress looks healthy and happy
just one month after giving birth